Oh steal Oh Smith with a tomahawk
that was quite asked that steal the
crowd pleases stuff already tonight and
make it two times Henderson with two
hands that would very little room and a
first maverick three-pointer of the game
[Applause]
all his efforts did is put it off poster
well if you're late rotating that's what
you'll get 564 steal by Smith jr. ahead
of the pack and now they're done 300 for
Dennis Smith junior get ready for the
slam dunk competition sure enough is
this is a lock
okay
[Applause]
that was like added bonus for those
staying until the final buzzer - Dennis
give me some love there he just dropped
the hammer makes it play good interior
deep
the electrified step by Smith jr. all
the way out to half-court by Serge Ibaka
[Applause]
is it a Ludacris I love the two hand
grab into one hand finish little extra
sauce today to get ready for this one
but the second one back to back
nonetheless all the way in for the
two-handed Jam just flying by the
Phoenix defense Wow and he exploded on
that day part you said come over to say
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
probably wasn't expecting that pass down
here that'll make posters anymore but if
they be it man
some dennis smith jr fan would be
hanging it up over his bed
what up it's your boy Adam left coach
you like that content I know you like
that content hit subscribe for more of
it from Bleacher Report